Speaker 1: Donald Trump reemerged over the
Halloween weekend after weeks of simply publishing
unhinged statement after statement to his
website in an interview with Fox News's Jeanine
Pirro now.
It was Halloween weekend.
This interview that Trump gave was way scarier
than any costume or any horror movie, that's
for sure.
So let's jump in.
Trump saying just days before tomorrow's Virginia
gubernatorial election, Trump arguing that
his endorsement is worth a lot.
He almost always wins, and he has endorsed
Glenn Youngkin.
Let's take a look at the clip.
Speaker 2: If I endorse somebody, they win.
If I endorse somebody, they win.
I think I'm one hundred and forty eight and
two.
That's a pretty good number.
You endorsed John King and I did endorse Youngkin,
and we're going to say I hope it's not going
to be free.
OK, do you understand that?
I did.
I endorse him strongly.
He's a good man.
Speaker 1: Now, the funny thing about the
Youngkin endorsement is that if youngin does
ultimately win tomorrow, Trump is obviously
going to say, Hey, that's another win in my
column.
That's another one that I endorsed and who
won.
If Youngkin loses tomorrow, Youngkin has actually
been distancing himself from Donald Trump
for the last month or so.
He appears to have calculated that Trump's
involvement may not actually help him defeat
Terry McAuliffe tomorrow.
So if Youngkin loses, of course, Trump is
going to say, you know, listen, I would have
brought him a win, but Youngkin didn't embrace
me.
That's why it's really Youngkin spot.
So Trump's going to take advantage of tomorrow's
results no matter what.
But what are what are the actual numbers on
the facts?
Trump's record is not that good on endorsements.
In the 2018 midterms, Trump endorsed 75 candidates
and a 55 percent of them one.
So Trump's record in 2018 was 55 wins, 45
percent losses, 55 percent wins, and he's
mostly endorsing incumbents.
So it's actually not so great of record and
ballot.
PDA looked at Trump's overall record during
his entire presidency.
They tracked 305 endorsements that Trump made,
and Trump's record in 2020, for example, was
that 77 percent of his endorses one.
Again, there is a bias to success because
Trump mostly endorses incumbents, and incumbency
has a huge advantage.
So it's really not that great of a record.
Let's look at a little bit more of this interview
that Trump gave Jeanine Pirro and just pick
up a couple of just wacky things, Trump says.
Speaker 2: OK, if there's one word that could
sum up the Biden administration, it would
be crisis.
There's the energy prices, the supply chain
crisis, the climate crisis.
If you look back on the last 10 months of
the Biden administration, what grade would
you give them?
Well, there's probably the worst presidency
in history.
I can't imagine I used to say Jimmy Carter,
not a big fan of Bush getting us into the
Middle East, to be honest with you, I think
this is though the worst in the history of
our country.
If you look at Afghanistan and that horrible
thing that happened to our nation with these
young people being killed and by the way,
so badly injured, we have over 20.
Speaker 1: Nor so remember when asked, Donald
Trump has not been able to articulate anything
he would have done differently in Afghanistan.
Let's go to I believe this is a discussion
of gas prices, and this is very interesting
because it's an opportunity for Trump, to
be honest, but he's not.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: Average American families spending
an extra one hundred seventy five dollars
a month.
Gas prices are up to $7 in California.
Five dollars in New York.
We can't afford these people and Joe Biden,
when he was asked about gas prices, what he's
going to do about it, he says, I don't see
anything that's going to reduce significantly
reduce gas prices in the future.
And he doesn't know.
No, he doesn't have any idea.
Look, one of the things I was most proud about
our country became energy independent.
Not true.
The Middle East, we didn't need Russia.
We didn't need anybody.
We had our own.
We had more than them.
We were number one by far over Saudi Arabia.
And you know this and Russia number one by
far.
I had the pipelines going Keystone XL pipeline.
Amazingly, I ended the Russian pipeline.
I was not good to Russia.
I got along well with Russia.
I got along well with Putin.
But they weren't happy with Trump.
I can tell you that.
But Biden opened up this big, massive pipeline
all over Europe, but he closed down the XL.
And I have to say, because you heard it a
thousand times.
More importantly, we're energy independent.
No longer.
I was so proud of that first time, really
in his
Speaker 1: understand that there has been
no appreciable change in the energy supply
configuration of the United States in the
10 months Joe Biden has been president and.
I mean, it's just Trump cites nothing.
It just hasn't happened, it's imaginary
Speaker 2: that we know they say seventy five
years, but I don't believe we will ever energy
independent.
When we were energy independent, we were doing
so much.
The prices, it was a dollar eighty seven a
gallon.
OK.
If you look at it, look at the numbers, the
crazy now.
Yesterday they had in a certain section of
California, seven dollars and 70 cents.
It's always the lead it's going to follow
and it's going to go a lot higher than that.
And Biden sent people to go see Russia, Saudi
Arabia and other members of OPEC that we need
help because we don't have enough.
Now when you talk about inflation, OK, so
Speaker 1: it would be really I actually think
Joe Biden should be applauded for what he
said during the town hall.
He said as as a president.
The one thing I can do probably only drops
gas 30 cents.
That is refreshingly honest because when it's
convenient, presidents love to pretend that
they they really have control over gas prices.
We're talking about global markets, we're
talking about supply chains that move really
slowly.
Now, in terms of Trump claiming gas was super
cheap, he mentioned a dollar 87 a gallon for
the four years that Trump was in office.
Gas prices were under two bucks a gallon for
only two months, April and May of 2020.
And that's because demand went to zero because
of the start of the pandemic, and it was where
people were traveling as little as we've seen
them travel, drive around, work from home,
started, etc.
It would be really refreshing if more president
said, Hey, you know what?
I know this is a popular political football.
But as presidents, we have very little control
over gas prices.
We have the Strategic Petroleum Reserve, which
on on a medium term basis could reduce prices
a little, but this is really much bigger than
us.
But of course, Trump doesn't do that horrifying
disinformation if you have the stomach for
it.
Check out the entire interview.
It's available on FOXNews.com.
We're going to leave it there.
Send me your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at Packman.
Remember that you can support our show and
the work we do and get some really cool extras
in so doing by signing up for a membership
at Join Pacman dot com, you'll get the Daily
Bonus Show, as well as commercial free audio
and video streams of the show.
So many great things, including priority access
to our viewer town halls, one of which we
had a couple of weeks ago.
We've got another one scheduled for soon.
I'll announce the date once I have it, but
it'll be probably in the next month, month
or five weeks or so.